hello everyone this this game I'm about
to show you was played in the Moscow
blitz tournament in 1992 and well
Michael Tao is playing with the white
pieces and Garry Kasparov is playing
with the black pieces so it's quite a
match and although there's a lot of
controversy to this game well I wanted
to know one thing that well Michael tile
came straight out of his hospital bed
just to play this tournament and so
let's see this game between these two
great players Michael Tao is white and
Casper is black so Michael table is
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 Bishop to b5
check Knight to d7 d 4 we have Knight to
f6 doll castles because power plays a6
Bishop captures on b7 night temperatures
on d7 Knight to c3 e 6 Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 rook to
e1 because power of casters on d4 and
tile captures with knight on d4 Knight
to e5 top plays f4 and cause power plays
h6 attacking the bishop so tile plays
Bishop to h4 and to the spiral plays g5
and here tau plays F captures on e5 a
very sharp move because power plays G
captures on h4 and now south plays he
captures on d6 and Bishop captures on d6
and in this position a Michael Tao plays
Knight to d5 so Kasparov captures he
captures on d5 he captures on d5 with
check from daruka me one and power plays
King to f8 and in this position
mikata played Queen to f3 and in this
position power of didn't resign will
rather the time on his clock ran out and
why I said that there's a lot of
controversy to this game a lot of people
say that this game didn't last only 70
moves that it lasted longer although
there aren't any
evidence to this claim and another thing
is that well because param is actually
better in this position but what you
should take into consideration is that
Kasparov uh well he had to spend a lot
of time to find the right moves to
review stout ideas and as part of
himself said in an interview after this
game that well even though he retaliated
in the second round and even though
Apsara won this tournament this game
against McHale tal is the only game he
lost and he said that even though he
calculates it extremely fast pal simply
doesn't have to calculate foul just sees
what move has to be played and so this
is the one last great game by Mikkel tau
well I say great because he made the the
reigning world champion lose some time
so this was Garry Kasparov of 1992 the
reigning world champion and well we
could say that this was Kasparov in his
prime and even he wasn't able to stop me
caught out with the white pieces
so yeah this and well maybe some of you
don't know this but one month after this
game was played Michael Tao died so yeah
a very nice game to remember and a nice
piece of chess history and well that's
it for this game I want to thank you all
for joining in on my streams I started
streaming some games well every day
since I'm on vacation now and there were
a lot of you in the stream almost 100
people and I hope I managed to play at
least each of you once and for those of
you who are interested tomorrow morning
at 9 a.m. I will be holding a tournament
for subscribers on Regis oh you're
welcome to join in on that so this is
the game last game played by Michael Tao
a less grey game against Garry Kasparov
and I hope you enjoyed this game as
short as it is but it again until this
illustrates nicely the style Tao Tao
always played in and this is style he
continued to play for the rest of his
life so
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and see soon